if there's one thing Dylan's an absolute
Master at it's staying relevant without
actually doing anything yes
um so you gotta get appreciate the
hustle if you can't give them credit for
anything whether he's fighting people
whether he's whether he's scheduling
matches that he's not going to take like
whatever whatever you have to say about
Dylan he definitely does a great job
we're talking about right now
he stays relevant he stays relevant but
he doesn't actually do anything yeah
it's impressive so you know
you know and then he like got into a
fight with khabib I get like five to ten
thousand followers overnight and I'm
just like man like he's not doing
anything but he's relevant so you gotta
at least give him credit for that